can you feel the center space gotta bake  nice me  it means it out I'm beyond grill just a  really exciting time I have it on repeat  it's a grown-up song for you yes the  last different from the music that I  started out doing and the mixtapes that  I've done up to this point it is I'm  excited about what people gonna feel  when they hear this album because it's a  very experimental album for me and I'm  trying a lot of new things and you know  just allowing myself to just freely  create no limits now I love the video  and had a very alia vibe was that  intentional emily is definitely a huge  inspiration of mine so I definitely feel  like you always see bits and pieces of  her so when people tell me that they see  little bits of pieces of Leah in the  video it's just like it means like I  don't know it's very special to me it's  definitely there and I chili is also  always there from TLC because you played  her had a little bit of TLC vibe pants  in the video